oui bonjour federica bonjour jimmy
bonjour à vous tous notre invité ce
matin et alex paviot bonjour bonjour
monsieur caruge boisjot aux auditrices
et auditeurs de martinique 1ère alex
paviot vous êtes membre donc du comité
de l'eau et de la biodiversité de la
martinique vous êtes représentants de la
chambre d'agriculture en quelque sorte à
l'office de l'eau et c'est à ce titre
que donc vous êtes au comité de l'eau et
de la biodiversité on vous a invité pour
nous parler de cette consultation du
public sur les enjeux de la gestion de
l'eau et des milieux aquatiques chez
nous puisqu'il ya eu une une enquête
donc 5700 martiniquais ont été
interrogées consultent et donc à propos
de cette gestion de ces enjeux de la
gestion de l'eau et donc il s'agit
d'identifier les priorités attendue pour
le prochain stage
le schéma directeur d'aménagement et de
gestion des eaux voilà on a planté le
cadre le décor maintenant alex preview
moi je vous demande qu'est ce que vous
retenez comme principaux enseignements
de cette consultation du public tout à
l'heure on a entendu la directrice du de
l'office de l'eau nous parler par
exemple de l'aspect de l'assainissement
mais il n'ya pas que celui-ci d'accord
donc bon tout d'abord je voudrais
rappeler un petit peu le rôle de comité
de loïc date biodiversité
évidement rapidement les rapidement qui
est composée de 40 membres qui s'assure
donc qui met à aa en oeuvre le sdage
schéma directeur de gestion de et
d'aménagement de l'eau à concertation
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de l'eau à
savoir les collectivités de communes des
communautés de communes est également
les associations de défense de
l'environnement etc et donc l'office de
l'eau c'est donc un petit peu le bras
armé de du comité de l'eau et de la
biodiversité est chargé de la mise en
application de
la politique générale l'a décidé c'est
un comité de l'organisme structure qui
donc regroupe les différents acteurs
autour de ce domaine là pour tenter de
créer une synergie une cohérence voire
même une cohésion cohésion dans les
actions pour voilà de ce point de vue
est ce que justement c'est efficace
parce que des fois on tombe et on met
différents acteurs dans une même
structure dans une même pièce mais s'ils
continuent à travailler chacun de leur
côté même en étant dans la même pièce
on n'a pas tellement fait avancer le
sujet quoi vous voyez ce que je veux
dire de mon point de vue la recherche
d'efficacité elle est permanente
donc c'est en concertation con qu'on le
trouve et donc le je dirais que bon le
comité de l'eau et de la biodiversité
en regroupant tous ces acteurs n'est pas
forcément omnipotent donc la compétence
eau est dévolue aux communautés
d'agglomération et bien entendu en
termes de gouvernance pour de mon point
de vue une structure unique de gestion
de l'eau serait beaucoup plus efficace
qu'une multiplicité de l'accord et on
n'y est pas encore on sait que c'est
quelque chose qui est réclamé de telles
excuses ailleurs réclamé par le public
le public alors on y revient justement
est-ce que ça vous a permis d'identifier
les priorités attendu par le public par
les usagers des eaux de la martinique
donc les usagers donc souhaite qu'il y
ait un petit peu le faire respecter un
petit peu les interdictions qui est plus
de répression qui a des engagements
politiques des corps donc là on est sur
la police de la baule et la gestion et
de la protection de la ressource
publique estime que willy action n'est
pas suffisante notamment dans l'aspect
répressif aller au delà de la simple
prévention
d'accord ça on retient déjà ce premier
aspect alesi un engagement plus
important sur le financement des
infrastructures et des subventions pour
la mise aux normes des
des fosses sceptiques puisque en terme
de deux subventions pour la mise en
place donc des réserves d'eau également
errance mort et la transparence et la
sécurité de l'alimentation à nous c'est
très important parce que moi j'ai
entendu ce matin
bon un petit peu ce qui se passe sur le
lamentin et ça attire notre attention
bon il est important de mettre en place
des politiques qui nous permettent de
prévenir et d'assurer la continuité de
l'alimentation à l'alimentation du
service public de la distribution de
l'eau alors je rappelle que ces avis
auprès de 5000 près de 6000 martinique
est à peu près donc 5700 exactement ces
avions été recueillies entre novembre
2018 et mai derniers à mai 2019
alors on nous dit donc tout ça permet de
dégager trois grands enjeux
donc
la ressource en eau donc il s'agit donc
de préserver de préserver en quantité et
en qualité
la ressource en eau et puis donc la
lutte contre les pollutions diverses là
dessus est ce que c'est un aspect qui
correspond au souci de protection de
l'environnement où ceux-ci écologistes
de plus en plus présent dans les esprits
des uns des autres est ce que c'est un
aspect qui va être vraiment prise en
compte mais je veux dire sérieusement
massivement danseuse d'âge donc sur la
période 2000 22 2025 ce schéma directeur
d'aménagement et de gestion des eaux que
vous préparez vous donc à 2027 2022 2027
voilà il a précisé me donc c'est la
révision de l'ancien stage donc que
normalement nous allons prendre en
compte les avis qui a été formulée par
la population ou justement amendé
l'ancien est passé à quelque chose de
plus actuelle en tenant en prenant
compte les aspects de changement
climatique
on voit bien que la ressource en eau
n'est pas toujours permanente avec des
sécheresses de plus en plus marquée et
une saison qui est un petit peu
fluctuante
donc ceci appelle beaucoup notre notre
attention
alors on consulte le public mais ça
passe par chacun d'entre nous aussi
cette affaire là est ce que il ya un
aspect de je dirais de
responsabilisation aussi du public
lui-même des uns et des autres dans la
gestion dans le non gaspillage on
parlait de pollution de protection et
bien en termes d'assainissement bon
voilà on sait qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont pas très
regardante sur le respect des règles en
l'occurrence et qui quelquefois
déversent des matières polluantes dans
les lits de rivières enfin que c'était
ça ou sur le littoral marin dernièrement
encore la plage de la française a été
interdite durant quelques jours à la
baignade donc voilà est-ce qu' il ya un
aspect
aussi auto responsabilisation des uns et
des autres oui toutes vos actions du
reste l'office de l'aube on s'acharne à
porter la communication auprès de la
population pour essayer de sensibiliser
au respect de l'environnement et au
respect des règles en matière de
pollution
donc c'est le rôle de l'aude et
également oui mais une fois qu'on a posé
ce principe les moyens qui permettent de
le faire davantage et de faire d'aller
au plus près des uns et des autres de
fait de le faire dans la vraie proximité
dans la vraie proximité effectivement
bon on doit dire aussi que bon le cette
consultation a été un vrai succès
puisque les martiniquais se sont
vraiment mobilisés ont répondu
massivement par rapport à la sienne
consultation ça pratiquement doubler le
nombre de réponses que nous avons
obtenus et et le biais donc avait mis en
place un certain nombre de moyens comme
les ambassadeurs bleus qui ont été
déployés en proximité justement sur le
terrain pour aller à la rencontre des
martiniquais et ça a permis du reste
quelques jeunes de de vraiment de ceux
de mettre un peu le pied à l'étrier pour
aller à la rencontre de la population
les sensibiliser justement sur les
actions à mener en termes de protection
de l'environnement et de gestion de
l'eau alors on va conclure
alex paviot membres donc du comité d eau
et de la biodiversité
le prix de l'eau courante est ce que
c'est une affaire donc vous préoccuper
aussi c'est une préoccupation du comité
de l'eau et de la biodiversité
du reste les associations aussi c'est le
prix trop élevé à vos yeux
encore oui en 2019
oui le prix trop élevés oui c'est ce que
c'est ce que font remarquer les
martiniquais et donc nous nous attelons
à faire en sorte de mettre en place une
tarification sociale de l'eau c'est ce
que nous avions souhaité mais pour
l'instant c'est un dossier qui demande
encore plus de réflexion
mais on s'y attelle dans ce schéma
directeur pour la paire que vous
préparez pour la période de 2022 2027 au
clan des actions à mettre en place
est-ce qu'ils ont ce camp il s'agit de
pouvoir retrouver notamment les rivières
parce que beaucoup de martiniquais qui
notamment certains qui ont au delà de 40
50 ans se souviennent comment justement
ils profitaient des rivières scène de
votre île on peut plus y pêcher quand on
se baigne bon bah on se demande si on va
pas attraper voilà ce que c'est un souci
qui va être aussi mise en oeuvre mise en
action dans ce stage en tout cas nous
nous a tellement à faire en sorte que
les rivières soit beaucoup mieux
entretenues et plus propres ainsi que
les sources
mais bon moi je me souviens de la
période où j'étais jeune gamin et où
j'allais à la rivière voir les jeunes
filles laver leur linge et tout ça donc
c'était c'était une belle époque et on
se baignait dans les rivières et
empêchait des écrevisses et ça c'était
vraiment la belle époque avec un débit
très intéressant alors les jeunes filles
qui l'avait fait venir découvrir les
voir c'est on se dit c'était mieux mais
entre temps il ya eu de la technologie
mais par contre pêcher des écrevisses et
ça bon voilà beaucoup aimeraient pouvoir
le refaire mais ça m'amène à parler de
la droite y un long et délicat approuve
ainsi jimmy d'ailleurs qui s'est
organisée après les années 60 a été mise
en place pour justement gérer les
conflits d'usagé
non mais je veux dire voilà plus
sérieusement ça demande des actions et
des moyens d accéder moyens qui sont
dans le stage parce que nous avons
quatre orientations fondamentales et
vous concluez là dessus rapidement merci
à travers ses orientations fondamentales
ça nous permet justement de mettre en
place une politique avec les plans
pluriannuels d'investissements qui sont
gérés par palau de1 donc c'est le le
comité de l'aude biodiversité qui
impulsent la politique et son bras armé
c'est donc le fils de baba nous
continuerons de suivre cela et nous
serons attentifs à ce qui sera mis en
place à propos de son ce dont nous avons
parlé entre 2022 et 2027 cesser bientôt
c'est demain oui oui le dernier mot pour
dire que bon le changement climatique
nous interpelle et je demande aux
agriculteurs bon de commencer à
réfléchir sur les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre pour sauvegarder leur production
et faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
organisation de gestion du risque de
manque d'eau et de l'excès d'eau
également voilà très bien vous allez
terminer avec ce message à l'intention
des agriculteurs puisque on le rappelle
alex preview vous êtes membre du comité
de l'eau et de la biodiversité
mais au titre de représentant de
l'assemblée cris culture au sein de
l'office de l'eau de la martinique merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions autour
donc de cette synthèse de la
consultation du public et des acteurs
autour de l'eau en martinique en vue de
la révision du zonage
merci d'avoir écouté bonne matinée bonne
journée même à toutes et à tous vous
retrouver federica et demi
[Musique]